- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is it doesn't
matter what your mom thinks.
Over to you Eckhart Tolle.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep my going.
- You get unhappy, if you.
For many years, before
I wrote The Power of Now
and it became successful.
I was basically a failure
in the eyes of the world.
So he's already almost 50.
And what has he achieved?
My mom said, you have
thrown away your life.
You had so many
possibilities in your life.
You walked out of graduate
school in Cambridge.
Why did you walk out of there?
My mom, and many other
people said this person
has failed in life.
He has no job, he has
no insurance policies.
Nothing.
No pension plan.
Just, almost nothing in the bank.
Failure
And then a few years later,
people bought The Power of Now
and became a best seller.
Now, a big success.
Okay if I had derived
my identity at that time
from what the world was telling me.
Or my mind would have told
me if I had been listening
to my mind, I would
have been very unhappy.
I didn't though.
I was fine.
Because my identity wasn't
derived from that anymore.
And fortunately even when
in the eyes of the world,
I suddenly became a success.
I don't want to derive my
from identity from that.
It's just a cheap substitute
for who I really am.
The satisfaction that
comes is the satisfaction
that the work that's happening.
The teaching that's happening
is transforming people's lives.
That's very satisfying.
But I don't get any personal
satisfaction though.
Because I don't feel that as
this separate me produced it.
- It would be great to have the support
of your mom, of your
parents, of your friends,
of your family, of your community.
To do whatever it is that you want to do.
But their support shouldn't be reflective
of whether you should
go up and do it or not.
Like, if your mom says this is a bad idea
that means you're not going to do it?
You know.
When you're growing up, when
you're five years old okay.
Listen to your mom, do what she says.
You get in trouble, right.
But how old are you now?
Like at some point you
decide, this is my life.
And I would love to have
the support of my parents.
And I had the support of my
parents while what I was doing.
It was great.
But if you don't have the support,
at what point do you decide
that you're an adult.
You're going to do the
thing that you want to do.
Are you going to be 40 years
old and still listening
to your parents and what they see for you?
And a lot of times,
especially your parents,
it's out of love.
Right?
They want you to be successful.
They want you to have a great life.
They just want you to
do it on their terms.
The way that they see
success may not be lined up
with how you see success.
And so they may not be
the ones telling you
that you suck and you'll
never be anything.
Though some parents are like that too.
Which that's a whole nother story.
But most of the time it's out of love.
It's out of them wanting
to see you be successful.
You just have different views
of what that looks like.
And at some point you have to
decide that this is my life.
I'm going to do things that I want to do.
And if you judge your
self worth based only off
of the results, then you're
never going to be happy.
You're never going to feel valuable.
Right?
And so, I look at my Youtube videos.
I look at this channel.
Look at what I'm making for you guys.
I love everything that I do.
I love the process.
This is why it's so important
that you love the process
of the work and not just the results.
It's not just about hittin
a million subscribers right?
That's my goal for the new year.
Have one million subscribers
let's see if we hit it.
It's not just about hitting
a billion entrepreneurs.
That's my lifetime goal.
I want to have a big impact.
I want to reach a billion entrepreneurs.
If I can do that and even
have a half a percent impact
on their life, all the things
that they're going to go off
and make is going to be insane.
And I'm honored to play a small tiny piece
in your success.
But it's not just about
hitting that number.
Because you can have a
goal, you can have a target.
And say I really want to reach this thing.
I'll do anything to get there.
But you won't do anything.
And you shouldn't do anything.
You can only force yourself
to do something you don't like
for so long.
You've got to do the work.
That Jerry Seinfeld calls
the torture you can endure.
The work that you love.
The torture that you love.
The process is more important
than hitting the goal.
I was asked if I'm going to do a big party
for hitting a million subscribers.
And I don't know.
Like, I do it more for you guys.
Than for me.
Right, we did one, we did a livestream
at half a million.
And I haven't done any other ones since.
We crossed a hundred million
views on the channel.
Which is awesome.
But once we've hit the
milestone, it's a great target
to go and reach.
But then it's in the past.
I don't want to live in the past.
I want to keep moving forward
we got more work to do.
We got more lives to change.
It's the process.
It's not just hitting
a million subscribers.
I could do that a lot faster
and a lot easier doing other things.
You know, if I was bashing entrepreneurs.
Bashing celebrities.
Saying all the negative things about them.
That would actually draw
a lot more attention.
I would get a lot more subscribers.
That's the sad state of humans.
We'd rather attack
somebody then embrace them
and learn from them.
We'd rather escape from
a life that we don't like
as opposed to try and build
a life that we do like.
And that's fine.
But I don't want to do that.
I would never be great at that.
I don't like bashing people.
I don't want to show the
negative sides of everybody.
'Cause everybody has a negative side.
It's not what I want
to put up to the world.
And so my only goal is I want
to hit a million subscribers
and I'll do anything I can to get there.
Those are the kind of
things I would be doing
but I'd never be great at them.
And I could never get to that goal.
Because that's not who I am.
It's cause I don't enjoy the process.
And so not everything
is going to be amazing.
There's a lot of crap
that you have to deal with
as an entrepreneur.
But if you just make it about the goal
and just hitting that mark
then you're never going to get there
and you'll really have to focus on
whether you're a writer,
whether you're a singer,
whether you're a dancer,
whether you're a Youtuber.
Whatever it is.
You're a software developer,
you have to enjoy writing code.
You have to enjoy the process
of figuring things out
and solving the problems.
And not just hitting a revenue target.
I think when you can do that.
When you can tie your
self worth into the work.
And say I'm proud of
this thing that I made.
Even if nobody else likes it.
This has been a lot of
videos that I put up
that you guys haven't liked.
That we've killed.
I'm still proud of them.
I still love them.
I was still like I am so
happy that I made that video.
I think it's great, it's genius.
But it didn't work.
So it's great, so it's good
for a certain amount of people.
It's good for me and a select few.
I can't build a business around it.
But I don't feel bad
about creating a series
that was a sinker, it was a loser.
Like that's a great piece of content.
I'm insanely proud of it.
And I think that as long as
you are insanely proud daily
of the work that you are creating.
And some of them are going to hit.
And some of them are going to miss.
In fact most of them are going to miss.
You're going to fail way more
then you're going to be a success.
But if you're proud of
the work and the hustle
that you're putting in daily.
Then you're not just getting
more self worth for yourself
and feel better about what
you're doing every day.
But eventually if you stick
with it, you'll get a career
and amazing business
that'll have a big impact
on the rest of the world.
So the question of the day today
is, I'm curious, does or
did your mom support you
in what you're doing right now?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I just want to give a quick
shout out to Shahrukh Hasan.
Shahruhk thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and taking that awesome,
exciting picture and
posting it to your Twitter.
I love the joy on your face.
Thank you so much for the
support and for enjoying my book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- Every pursuit, no matter
how glamorous it may seem,
no matter how exciting it feels to you,
no matter how much you were born to do it,
comes with a shit sandwich.
And so the question is not what do I love.
The question is what do I love so much
that I don't mind eating the shit sandwich
that comes along with that thing.
So for me and my life, writing
is the thing that I love.
And the shit sandwich was the seven years
that I was not getting published.
And that I was coming home from my job
as a diner waitress, as a
bartender, as an au pair,
as somebody who worked in
flea markets, as a cook.
And I was coming home tired
and smelling like other
people's french fries.
And sitting down and doing my real job.
Which was to write.
And then to go to the
mail box the next day
and get another rejection letter.
And then say, do I still want to do this?
'Cause this shit sandwich sucks.
(laughter)
- Am I ready to take another bite?
- And I did still want to do it.
And now even as somebody who
makes their living as a writer.
There's no end to the shit sandwiches.
It's like, oh hello horrible
review in prominent newspaper.
That's your shit sandwich today Liz.
You still want to do this work?
Yeah I still do, still worth it.
Like hello awful comment on social media
from somebody who thinks
you're a pile of dog shit.
(laughter)
You know and just like
chosen every possible way,
that they just cannot get it
out of their system fast enough
how much disregard they
have for your entire life.
Still want to do this thing?
Yeah I still want to do it.
So that's the question.
Because if the first time
you encounter the shit
sandwich you're like,
well this isn't worth it.
Then that's not the thing
you're supposed to be doing.
And there are plenty of
things in life that I have run
into the shit sandwich and
been like so not worth it.
(laughter)
So not worth it, like this is
not, I don't want to do this.
Like whatever the alleged
benefits of this thing might be.
No, this whole cycle, no.
(laughter)
You know, like I know it's
probably really good for me
but I feel like throwing up right now
cause this is too hard.
You'll not be seeing me here again.
You know, and I love my
sisters at Soul Cycle.
I just don't like feeling
like I'm going to throw up.
When I exercise.
So it's not for me.
And so that's the question.
So if you go into this thing thinking,
if I follow my bliss, and I live my dream,
and I stand in my truth, that
everything will be great.
It doesn't mean everything will be great.
It just means at the end of the day
when you check in with yourself
and you go, in the end, on the balance,
is this still better than not doing it?
And the answer is still yeah
this thing's still better
than not doing it, then
you're on the right path.
- I knew I wanted to be
in the skate industry.
I loved skating too much.
I wanted to be in it.
I didn't know if I would make a living
as a professional, but I was
going to be, I was devoted
to skateboarding so.
I refinanced my house
and took all the money
and started a skateboard company.
Which seems like the stupidest
thing in the world to do
when skating's dying but,
it was exactly what I wanted to do.
I wanted to be a company
owner, be behind the scenes.
I quit my sponsor and started
and for about three years
struggled very hard.
With, my partner and I we had
pooled our money together.
He was an ex pro skater as well.
And we just did Birdhouse.
Did whatever we could to get by
and all the team was staying on my couch.
Literally like while I'm changing diapers,
I'm like driving guys to these spots
that they're going to get arrested at.
Because there's no skate parks
so they're going to go ride school yards
and (laughing) it was
such a strange existence.
But I loved it, because
it was skateboarding
and it was exactly what I wanted to do.
And so, we really hunkered down you know.
I was living on Taco Bell
and peanut butter jelly.
And Top Ramen.
- [Interviewer] Mmm.
- For probably three years for sure.
But I didn't care 'cause
it was like I still got
to do what I love.
That's the thing is that people think,
was it a struggle?
Well no, because I loved it too much.
I still got to go skate.
And I had time to skate.
I didn't have to go sit behind
a computer for eight hours
and then hope I get time to skate.
- I've never been interested
in living a balanced life.
I think that balanced people
don't change the world,
first of all.
I think balanced people
don't really follow a dream.
This doesn't mean that you
don't have responsibilities.
Like just go to the other
part of this question,
how can you have a family.
Well sure you can have a family.
But balance is kind of
like, I feel like balance
is like a made up word, it's
like invented by corporations.
You know to make their employees
think that they're happy.
It's like you've got this balance.
Like you could work at Microsoft you know
or something here in Seattle.
- [Interviewer] There's
like 10 Microsoft people
in the audience here.
- No disrespect to Microsoft.
Let's pick another company,
Microsoft's a great company.
- [Interviewer] One out of
every five people in Seattle
works at Microsoft.
- That's right you know, and
it's like you got this thing.
And maybe you love your job.
And if you love your job that's great.
But I hear from a lot
of dissatisfied people
at these big companies and they write in
and they're like I'm reading
your blog from my cubicle
and I have this good job,
I have my health insurance,
I've got free yoga every Thursday.
But I'm not really, you know,
- [Interviewer] Fulfilled.
- Right, I'm not really fulfilled.
So for me I guess I'm much more interested
in that word fulfilled.
How can you live a fulfilled life?
You can live a fulfilled life
and still pay your bills.
Lots of creative people do it.
Lots of unconventional people do it.
I would say if anything it's
actually much more common now
than it used to be.
When I first started
working online 15 years ago,
I didn't know a lot of other
people who were doing that.
My friends thought I was
selling drugs or something.
- [Interviewer] Well you were (laughing).
- Well I was, you know, but,
or like online gambling.
Or you know whatever,
like parents have no idea
how the internet works.
But now it's much more common.
So I don't really like
the word balance myself.
- [Interviewer] So what we'd like to do
is we'd like to replace the word.
Like living a balanced
life is not the goal.
The goal is living a fulfilled life.